joining me now is daisy cooper the
deputy leader of the liberal democrats
good morning um good morning
congratulations on tivotton uh your vote
shared jumped pretty
dramatically uh it says hero by over 38
percentage points um do you expect to
repeat that as a general election
well first of all um the result in
tibetan and hunterton was a historic
victory for the liberal democrats we
have just achieved overturned the
biggest majority in a by-election ever
in british political history so of
course we are indeed buoyant when it
comes to the next general election we
are hoping to win seats off the
conservative party we are the key
challenges in many places across the
country and we'll be working very hard
to get as many of those seats as
possible yeah you didn't do it on your
own uh did you um actually you you were
able to
turn that performance uh because labour
basically
went off the pitch and lost its deposit
well actually the reason we won tivot
and huntington was because not only did
labour voters lend us their vote but
thousands and thousands and thousands of
former cons former conservative voters
who are quite frankly sick of a prime
minister who is breaking the law and the
government that has no plan for the cost
of living crisis they also decided to
vote for our candidate um to be a strong
community champion for tiveton and
honniton and they chose to vote for us
because we are setting out a plan as to
how to tackle the cost of living
emergency that is facing families up and
down this country mr lammy uh told me um
a few minutes ago that um you should be
happy because
labour people lent you their vote but he
implied that they were going to take him
back we've been here before haven't we
big lib dem
uh wins in by-elections in between and
then the seats go right back
well if you look at sarah only seat for
example in south london she won her seat
in a by-election and she's still an mp
today i think what we're seeing is a
strong pattern we saw in cheshire
amisham in buckinghamshire and then in
north shropshire now in devon the
liberal democrats are winning seats off
the conservatives with very large
majorities and the reason for that is
that this conservative government does
not have a plan and the liberal
democrats do have a plan we are in the
middle of a cost of living emergency
people up and down the country can see
that the conservative government is
sitting on its hands whilst liberal
democrats are putting out practical
ideas as to how to tackle it but you'll
understand why viewers will be a bit
puzzled by this um
both you and labour people come on this
program and you say the worst thing in
the world is a continued boris johnson
administration but the one thing you
will not do is
have a pact or any kind of alliance or
even an understanding which would
guarantee that there are more tiverton
and honetons between you and that the
tories get pushed out
explain why that is so impossible and
you know the argument that voters don't
like it
either you believe voters don't want the
tories in or
there's some other reason why can't you
guys get together
i think there is a really big
distinction between a hypothetical
situation that may or may not happen in
a couple of years time and the reality
of what we're facing right now as an
opposition mp i can see day in day out
how the inaction of this conservative
government is hurting families in my
constituency and around the country and
that is why right now i can look at the
conservative government and decide i
want them out of power i want them out
of office and that's why liberal
democrats are putting forward these
concrete ideas like the windfall tax
like an emergency vat cuts like a
windfall tax on bankers bonuses we are
the party putting forward these ideas to
tackle the crisis that is facing people
right now i i didn't hear in that answer
a rejection of an idea of an
understanding
well that's because we're talking about
hypothetical situations it's not
hypothetical everybody knows that if you
did what you did in tibetan and honest
and you'd you'd win lot more a lot more
seats you haven't said we won't do it
well liberal democrats will continue to
try and win seats off the conservatives
in the sea in areas where we are the key
challenges the fact is if you look at
the last two years things have changed
so much nobody had expected the pandemic
or anything else we simply can't work
out what will happen in the future all
right well let's let's um imagine that
there might be a liberal democrat
component in a future government you'd
have to deal with the sort of thing
that's going on this week uh strikes
your transport spokesperson condemned
the government for making
uh i think the quote was no effort to
stop these strikes um what would your
effort be how would you tackle this
i think it is extraordinary
that with the threat of strikes and of
course there is uh threats of summer of
strikes as well in any other time with
any other prime minister a prime
minister would have used the power of
number 10 to get people around the table
to knock heads together and to thrash
out a deal we have a prime minister who
is missing in action we have a transport
secretary who just admitted that he
hadn't
met with the unions for more than a
month i think many people are very
sympathetic to the fact that there are
people on low incomes
who are really struggling with the cost
of living crisis and they recognize that
this government hasn't done enough and
they recognize that frustration but but
i don't i don't agree with the strikes
but i do think the government should be
using its power to get people around the
table so the liberal democrat policy is
that tried and trusted 1960s policy beer
and sandwiches at number 10 ministers
sitting with unions and employers
knocking heads together getting a deal
which mostly meant the taxpayer funded
it
so what we have suggested is actually
there should be an independent public
sector paid body that can look at this
issue right across the board for the
public sector it works incredibly well
with the low pay commission that sets
the national minimum wage i think the
same thing could be done for the public
sector as a whole that would take the
politics out of this issue and it would
get a fair deal for people who are on
low incomes and struggling with the cost
of living daisy cooper thank you very
much indeed for joining us this morning
thank you